[Music]
welcome to another episode of whatsa
Prof hello Walter hi
Martin H we are busy with this work that
we're going to talk about today but the
work is
great and the work is of you yeah so we
need help so let's open with a word of
prayer our heavenly
father we know that we are rushing
towards that great
day and like you've mentioned in the
Bible and we just mentioned
now the work is
great but the workers are few and we
need help so help us also now with the
Holy Spirit to bring about over a
message that you would want us all to
hear in Jesus name amen
amen
well Martin there are couple of
interesting parallels in the Bible about
the
work and uh I think you know once you
start becoming involved in the work you
will
realize that it is of such great
extent that you cannot possibly tackle
all the Avenues yourself
no there has to be a coordinated effort
and there must be a passion that
develops that can only be induced by the
Holy Spirit yeah thing is that if you
are constantly in secular activities and
busy in your secular life and you do the
work of God only every now and then as
you see as you have time it's different
from when you start realizing how great
this work is and you become ful involved
in it and there will always be stumbling
blocks in the way and the devil will
roll stones in your path and our first
our first impulse is I can't do it yeah
even Moses said I can't do it the second
one is send someone
else even Moses said send someone
else uh and then he said I can't speak
yeah
and isn't God the one who made the
tongue how many times do you hear but I
can't speak in front of people all right
so in his compassion God decides all
right I'll put someone by your side who
is very proficient in the Egyptian
language so that you can speak to
Pharaoh then you don't feel all
alone but uh you you are going to be the
leader and he is going to be second in
command now that must have been
difficult too because Aaron was the
older one and Moses was the younger one
and now this young guy wants to tell you
I mean young guy 80 years
old to tell him what to do but you know
in his mind he's still the younger
brother
yeah but that's how it works and that's
uh all about character
so let's have a look at this topic that
we want to
discuss so we've titled it the work is
great so let's have a look at the some
of the typologies offerings for the
temple 1 Chronicles 29 verse1
furthermore David the king said unto all
the
congregation Solomon my son whom alone
God has chosen is yet young and tender
and the work is great
for the palace is not for man but for
the Lord
God but there's a Temple to be built
yeah there was the physical Temple and
the work was great there was the
physical Temple and the work was local
mhm here at the end of time there's a
spiritual Temple because Paul says ye
are the Temple of the Living God
speaking to the churches right so if we
go to that text in 1 Peter 2:9 but ye
are a chosen generation a royal
priesthood a holy nation A peculiar
people that you should F forth the
Praises of him who has called you out of
Darkness Into His Marvelous
Light I think our backdrop sort of
summarizes that don't you think Mar draw
you into His Marvelous
Light there it is and people coming
towards The Marvelous Light from all
walks of life every nation tribe and
tongue and
people and this
light represents Christ right that's I
am the light of the world so you have to
bring them to Christ but Christ has
comes with a package deal yeah if you
love me keep my Commandments it was not
so in the
beginning so how do you go back to the
beginning well we talked about that in
the last one everything has to change
the old person has to die yeah I am a
new person you have to be born again by
the spirit all things have become new
says the Bible your own mother doesn't
recognize you yeah that's it so
Martin it takes people who have been
born again to recognize the greatness of
the work and the importance of this
disseminating the light along with the
other criteria that's also part of what
you have to do to be part of the last
generation yes because if you want to be
built into this last Temple the
spiritual Temple this house of God that
is being raised
up there is not only a work to the
outside that has to be done it's not
just a question of soup
kitchens there is a
spiritual regeneration and renovation
that must take place if any of your
efforts are without a an spiritual e um
supporting effort going with it what's
the use no there must be a hewing of the
stones and we are living stones yeah and
some people think well I'll start when
that process is finished no the work
starts when the process
starts in other words when you come out
of the Waters of baptism the first thing
you have to do is start working and then
you get a couple of
wax and sometimes it doesn't stop no and
they just get harder and the intensity
varies M but that's where it starts and
in this process of disseminating truth
being changed yourself being hued and
squared in the Quarry of
Life polishing up against other Stones
bashing against other stones but
fortunately that never happens to us we
never have to have conflicts of bashing
and squaring and hueing right no it's
smooth sailing I don't know what the
people are complaining about when
they're trying to do the Lord's work
I don't know what it is all about some
seem to claim that they have achieved
Perfection I wish I were at that stage
but uh well they I doubt if they've been
in a
Ministry some of them might be in a
Ministry but you know not until this
vile body has turned into his glorious
body can we say that our troubles and
stries are over that doesn't mean we
mustn't strive for it oh you must strive
forward because uh only those who strive
and seek to enter into that narrow
doorway along that narrow Stony
path they will be the ones that will
eventually stand on the sea of glass and
also just for in case people
misunderstood what we just said this is
all attainable only through Christ that
works in you correct here are men who
are standing at the head of our various
institutions of the educational
interests and of the conferences in
different localities in the different
states all these are to stand as
representative men to have a voice in
the molding and fashioning the plans
that shall be carried out there are to
be more than one or two or three men to
consider the whole vast field the work
is
great I love it don't
you and there is no human mind that can
plan for the work which needs to be done
Martin if God is not in the work we
might as well not start no that's it
give up don't even go there and Moses
realized that when he said to God okay
if you're going to leave us now then
we'll just stay here because if you're
not going to go with us we're not moving
even the disciples when they when Jesus
asked them do you also want to leave it
where should we go there's no other way
and I want to say God has not put any
kingly power in our ranks to control
this or that branch of the work the work
has been greatly restricted by the
efforts to control it in every line
there must be a renovation a
reorganization a power and strength must
be brought into the Committees that are
necessary now this is a point that the
world just cannot understand no they
cannot understand no because the worldly
corporate system is opposite to this
completely the opposite so there is no
kingly power amongst us we have no King
but Jesus that means that in this work
you and I are brothers yes and that
means that we collectively have a task
and indiv individually have a task and
are accountable to God Alone taking into
consideration the collective ideas of
many very difficult because selfishness
says I will rule my way or the
highway we saw it in the history of this
church kog for example
and the results thereof yes so in the
Council of many there is
wisdom but if a council doesn't move
over to action then there is a spiritual
death yeah so no kingly power amongst us
we work as brothers and
sisters there is no Pope amongst us and
never shall there be a pope amongst us
the president and business manager are
to be regarded as bearing a United
responsibility the work is
great and if the business of
financiering is so conducted that there
is a departure from the Simplicity of
the work if money is absorbed for the
sake of appearance in order as Men
supposed to give character to the work
weakness and not strength will result
and the board of directors and
counselors two or three men are not to
Confederate together to carry out their
own ideas this must be strictly guarded
against for in pursuing such a course
there is danger that Injustice will be
done so M when you want to work in
harmony with
God then you must work along the lines
that God has given us
no kingly power you must have a a board
that is the final decision making body
and then the
individual aspirations must be laid
aside or must be the collective idea of
the entire group before you continue
along those lines and we must never
forget the Simplicity of the work
exactly that's a very important point
the Simplicity of the work God's work is
not complicated no and as soon as you
complicate it you're doing Injustice to
it and it's not flashy no no it's simple
it's not flashy tasteful but it is yes
it is done with taste and it's uh to be
presented as a noble
work so
you have to find that balance that's
it never never was there a time when our
hearts were more in Earnest than now the
work is great the time is short the end
is near the rebuke of God is upon all
self-sufficiency we must walk humbly
before God and depend holy upon the
merits of a crucified and Risen Savior
clothed with the garments of Christ's
right nness we may then appear before
God so there must be no selfishness in
this work selfishness and pride was the
fall of
Lucifer no selfishness no pride no
Superior kingly
power difficult Concepts the Lord said
You shall not Lord it over each other as
the Gentiles do there must be a
brotherly uh cooperation among you you
must see eye to eye and the work is
great and you must use the merits the
righteousness of Christ is absolutely
the essence of everything that you have
to do so let's go back to our typology 1
Chronicles
29:2 now I have prepared with all my
might for the house of my God this is
David speaking the the gold for things
to be made of gold and the silver for
things of silver and the brass for
things of brass the iron for things of
iron the wood for things of wood the onx
stones and stones to be set glistering
stones and of diverse colors and all
manner of precious stones and marble
stones in
abundance wasn't that was a physical
house mhm a physical Temple now if
you're going to build a spiritual house
or are you going to build with literal
gold
no so what does the gold stand for the
gold of a fear it must be character
right yeah what does the silver stand
for the silver must be character that
has been purged of the dross yeah
because the silver has to be purified
yes the has to be taken out and it's
effort it's not easy
yes was there brass in the temple yes
now brass has elements in it of copper
and of iron and all of these things
together and it's very much stronger but
highly polished bras can glisten like
gold yes yes I mean if you even the
Shields and um all of that that the
Greeks wore yes it shown sh like was a
military weaponry of of that them so
this is some of the basa work that has
to be done character building is first
and it's interesting that it never stops
because uh you always have to repolish
silver gold and
brass and the things of brass and iron
for things of iron and wood for things
of wood and onx stones and stones to be
set there is a a level of work at every
level it's not just the higher work
there is the mundane work that has to be
done as well so it's a great work it is
an enormous
work so Earthly kingdoms also have
elements of gold silver brass and
iron but they are here symbols of
selfishness and lording it over the
others what God desires is the true
metal of character
development so with within this house
there will be a lot of hu and squaring
and polishing that goes on because it is
a living house
yeah this is a living Temple and have
you ever noticed
that if you haven't if you haven't
noticed it yet then you're probably not
part doing the work that you you're
still on the first step I can't do it I
can't do
it all right so it's a great work and
it's individual work and there are
different levels of
work you can you can honor the process
by doing the simple
tasks sometimes that's overseen you see
that's the problem every everybody wants
to do something great for the Lord and
then they neglect the small things that
has to be done for him correct so Martin
the Bible talks about uh being tried in
the fire
fire Zechariah 13:9 and I will bring the
third part through the fire and I will
refine them as silver is refined and I
will try them as gold is tried they
shall call on my name and I will hear
them I will say it is my people and they
shall say the Lord is my God so M to be
part of this Temple is a painful
experience yeah that's it don't expect
any less and if it does come don't run
away don't wi
yeah right and people say oh
everything's going wrong with him he
must be doing something wrong maybe
everything's going wrong with him
because he's finally doing something
right and people say you know if God is
on his side why do these things happen
to
him if God is on his side why should
these things not happen to him didn't it
happen to every Bible figure that's it
and maybe it's happening because he's
God is on his God is on his side okay so
serving God is a joyful painful
experience combined the whole time all
right so we pick up this same idea in
Zechariah in the Book of Revelation
chapter 3 I counsel thee to buy of me
gold tried in the fire that thou mayest
be rich and white rment that thou mayest
be clothed and that the shame of thy
nakedness do not appear and anoint thine
eyes with isol that thou mayest see
Martin this is such an important
process that we should put on the
righteousness of Christ which is made
manifest by obedience to all his
Commandments not only the 10 but all the
others as well we've discussed that at
length part of the work is great there's
a work to the outside and there's a work
to the
inside 1 Chronicles 29:3 and onwards
moreover because I have set my
affections to the house of my God I have
of my own proper good in other words his
own
possessions of gold and silver which I I
have given to the house of my God over
and above all that I have prepared for
the holy
house can you expect
Martin to get anywhere if you are not
willing to
sacrifice no not in the secular World
nowhere if you're not willing to
sacrifice and put the hand to the plow
it's not going to work anyway you don't
just get everything for fre does it
necess necessarily have to be physical
money no no can be your effort mhm can
be the prayers that you make for other
people it can be the word of
encouragement stewardship of your life
it can be Hospitality to make people
comfortable there are many many things
that you can bring to the house of the
Lord and say this is my
offering uh is being approachable an
important thing yes
would you want to be a recluse in the
house of God no hide yourself behind
curtains and a closed door would you
want to do that it's not um God's way
all right there are times when you must
come aside and rest a while but uh Jesus
always went back into the crowds and he
made himself available in fact he was
poured out like a drink
offering so these are all things that we
can do and if you have means
then you must be prepared to give those
means for the
calling yes some are able to physically
do the others are able to provide for
the others to do yes for example
Nicodemus was a wealthy
man and if it weren't for him the early
church would have been in Dire Straits
because he funded a lot of the programs
of the early church so yes we need
funding but is funding enough is it
enough to say okay I have means I'll add
that no because you can't neglect all
the other things that go along with it
right that's true including the hueing
and squaring of the own character yes so
it's not it's not like a
philanthropic exercise you're right it
has to do with our chains as well why do
you do it and most of those things that
you do don't get into the headlines no
if if they do get in the headlines
you're probably on the wrong side of the
fence
true all right so 1 Chronicles 29
verse4 even 3,000 talents of gold of the
gold of a fear that's very fine gold and
7,000 Talons of refined silver to
Overlay the walls of the house with all
the gold for things of gold the silver
for things of silver and for all manner
of work to be made by the hands of the
artificers and who then is willing to
consecrate his service this day unto the
Lord Buton is that a question we need to
ask ourselves yes because that's what we
just mentioned if you just give are you
consecrated towards the service of the
Lord doesn't the Lord say to the prophet
whom shall I send and what does that
Prophet answer Here I Am Lord send me
that must be all of us every one of us
must answer a call Here I Am Lord Here I
Am
Lord right how shall we follow Christ
and serve him in the home life and in
the missionary work abroad if he bids us
go the cross will have to be lifted if
the Lord bids anyone in his service to
leave their family and relatives and his
large circle of friends that would
interfere with the true service that God
requires both at home and abroad there
must be self sacrifice on the part of
some because of the dear wife and
children but God requires just this of
some others may act in accordance with
the will of God and take their families
with them but it is wholehearted
self-sacrificing service which the Lord
demands love for God and devotion in his
work will not diminish in the least the
love for wife and children and home and
because of his love for those dear to
him the true missionary will pray for
wisdom to do the work as a faithful
servant of Jesus Christ so not everybody
is called to leave house and family you
can work within the circle of your
environment some of them are called and
so it's also important not to stand in
the way or to criticize those that are
called to go and serve out of away from
their families or in other countries we
should support each other in this work
yes I mean if you look at the Spirit of
Prophecy how often did Elam white
complain to God that she couldn't do it
now because you know she had a family
newborn babies and the Lord said I can
solve that problem I can take the baby
away would you like that
and the baby was sick and she wrapped it
up and put it under the coach in the
middle of winter and thought this is
never going to work and the the child
got better in that cold freezing weather
open snow Carriage correct so sometimes
you get called to do that in my own
situation there were many many that
criticized you neglecting your family oh
yeah by doing what you do and uh do
these people think that it was easy to
leave home and family and wife and
children no it wasn't easy but God
blessed in amazing ways so not everybody
is called to do that and I understand
that that would make this world very
chaotic but if you are called to do that
put the shoulder to the wheel do it and
if you are not called to do it doesn't
mean you don't have a work to do of
course and you support both you support
the people that has to to go and you
support the people that has to stay
correct so she continues here in letters
and manuscripts and the wife and
children may unite in missionary work at
home all bound upon the altar with
golden cords all United to do and suffer
for Christ's sake if need be committing
all to God as to a faithful Creator the
one who loves God supremely finds his
heart overflowing with love for his dear
ones and he knows that the God he serves
will bless and hallow that love for they
are holding up his hands and
strengthening his soul so if you do the
work of God then God will take care of
the issues that you think will be
neglected and sometimes Martin they may
seem to be neglected that's it but in
the meantime God is working there and
God is using even those circumstances to
further his work and to bind things
together let's continue with Chronicles
then the chief of the fathers and the
princes of the tribes of
Israel and the captains of thousands and
of the hundreds with the rulers of the
king's work offered
willingly so Mar those who stand in
leading
positions must set an example that's
true
they should be the first ones to give
that's it to the there is a example that
leadership has to do yes all right so
you have to support the work with your
means you have to support the work with
your efforts and if you are in a
position where you know you have some
Authority in this work or
whatever then there is a double portion
upon you then you should do it not
grudgingly but willingly so you see that
is very important the W willing offering
because here David was speaking about to
or talking about building this Temple
and eventually when Solomon built
it he went over a part of these willing
workers because he went and fetched
people slaves to come and work on the
temple and he went to people that were
not necessarily consecrated by God to do
the work and they were interested in
doing it for money exactly so that's the
free offering the willingness to do it
not for gain I heard one evangelist say
martin that if he should ever be put
into a position of high leadership he
would immediately fire every single
Pastor in the entire world
fire them
all and then after 3 months see who's
still
working and then hire all those back
exactly but uh that's a that's a way in
which man would do it but that's the way
you can see who is actually consecrated
to do the work correct but God in his
kindness doesn't do that so he wants you
in spite of the one who's not doing the
work to don't carry on doing that's true
that's true don't let the others don't
let anybody discourage you from doing
the work put your faith in God and he
will help you then you can say instead
of I can't I will correct and he gave
for the service of the house of God gold
5,000 Talons 10,000 grams and of silver
10,000 Talons and of brass 18,000 Talons
and 100,000 Talons of iron and they with
whom precious stones were found gave
them to The Treasure of the house of the
Lord by the hand of jeel the ganite now
what why does the bible list these
quantities it's to show you that they
were really willing that's it they
weren't grudgingly
giving then the people
rejoiced for they offered willingly
because with perfect heart they offered
willingly to the Lord and David the king
also rejoiced with great joy
so is there joy in this
work yeah for sure in spite of the Hing
and the squaring mhm yes which
unfortunately Joy yeah Christ came to
this world to reveal the love of God his
followers are to continue the work which
he began let us strive to help and
strengthen one another seeking the good
of others is the way in which true
happiness can be
found selfishness makes you a narrow
person
Martin man does not work against his own
interest by loving God and His fellow
men the more unselfish his Spirit the
happier he is because he is fulfilling
God's purpose Pur for him the Breath of
God is breathed through him filling him
with gladness to him life is a sacred
trust precious in His sight because
given by God to be spent in ministering
to others so true happiness comes when
you minister to others it's a it's a
difficult concept sometimes to
understand and you know in this world of
Ms and and shopping frenzies and all of
these things do we do we find time to
reflect on these spiritual aspects yeah
you see the other thing is like we've
mentioned here we're talking about a
spiritual Temple this is the Church of
God so are we more invested in Earthly
things with a happy heart or are we
invested in God's work with a happy art
okay let's look at
our backdrop
again the work is great and few are the
workers and our text was that we should
bring people to the light in Christ is
the
light so you see the people walking
towards the light now some of them you
know might like moths might be just
drawn to the
light but some of them are also
destroyed when they fly into the flame
yeah so you have to you have to
appreciate the light you must understand
what the light is all about you must
understand why you want to draw people
to the light it is it is such a profound
message and then you have David's prayer
to the
assembly wherefore David blessed the
Lord before all the congregation and
David said blessed be thou Lord God of
Israel Our Father forever andever ever
thine O Lord is the greatness and the
power and the glory and the Victory and
the
Majesty in other words you must always
attribute any successes to God for all
that is in heaven and the Earth is thine
thine is the kingdom O Lord and thou art
exalted as head above all both riches
and honor come of thee and thou reignest
over all and in thine hand is power and
might and in thine hand is it to make
great and to give strength unto all now
therefore Our God we thank thee and
praise thy glorious
name is that a profound
prayer that's a thing he's blessing God
and all of that never complaining or
murmuring and everything is from him
that's it so where did you get what you
were going to give whether it is a
talent whether it is an attribute
whether it is financial where did you
get it from in the first place from him
in the first place it's like when people
give their tithes you're not giving your
tithe to God you're actually giving back
what is
his portion of what is his that's right
you're giving a portion of what is
his so the contrast of this attitude and
the result thereof is what what's the
opposite of this attitude in other words
what's the absolute opposite
Nebuchadnezzar Daniel 4:30 the king
spoke and said is not this the great
Babylon that I have buil for the house
of the Kingdom by the might of my power
and for the honor of my
Majesty for sure can you see why this
man had to eat
grass yes I think a lot of us has to eat
grass you're not referring to the
vegetarian are you
Martin like I mentioned before do you
get hungry when you're mowing the lawn
no
no no we're in the spiritual place where
King Nebuchadnezzar was all right
Revelation 16: 19 and the great city was
div divided into three parts and the
cities of the Nations fell and great
Babylon came into remebrance before God
to give unto her the cup of the wine of
the fierceness of his wroth so the
attitude that we find in King
Nebuchadnezzar is the same attitude we
will find in the anti-typical Babylon
that's true well I was just thinking
when you mentioned this now the grass
eating after that his mind became clear
so that uh diet wasn't that bad was it
well you're taking you're taking an
interesting turn
there but we did Health last time so we
so we we'll give the people a break
right all right Martin so if you have
this mindset tell me in modern
Babylon do you have gold and silver and
brass and metal and stone and precious
stones and everything in it oh yeah have
you ever walked into a great Cathedral
no actually no you haven't been in a
great Cathedral no haven't you been to
the VA no not to the Vatican you haven't
been to the Vatican okay that's okay
Martin you haven't you haven't missed
anything no I don't have any intention
of going it's better to worship under a
tree than to be there and see the Pomp
and the glory and the glitter well
that's what got to Martin Luther when he
got there for the first time yes so here
you have this uh mindset that you had in
King
Nebuchadnezzar the Pomp and the glory
but it is to gratify self yeah but who
am I says David in
Chronicles who am I and what is my
people that we should be able to offer
so willingly of to this sort for all
things come of thee and of thine own
have we given thee exactly the opposite
isn't that exactly the
opposite for we are strangers before the
and Sous as were all our fathers our
days on the Earth are as a shadow and
there is none abiding oh Lord our God
all this store that we have prepared to
build thee a house for thine Holy Name
cometh of thy hand and is all thine
own how do we instill that
mindset you can't only God can okay and
we must let him I know also my God that
thou triest the heart and has pleasure
in
uprightness see can you separate the
personal character building from the
external work that must be done no it's
once again if the it's like keeping the
Commandments you cannot keep the
Commandments to be saved but when you
are saved you want to keep them this is
the same then he says as for me in the
uprightness of mine heart I have
willingly offered all these things and
now have I seen with joy thy people
which are present here to offer
willingly unto thee the bottom line
Martin
is everybody is involved in this work
and everybody has a work to do everybody
if for God you all of us I'll give an
example we've we at the end of the year
there's a whole year next year that the
positions in the church has to be filled
and people have a work to do don't let
two or three people have to work
themselves into the ground we all have a
duty in God's Temple so the people
actually had to go and lift up the hands
of Moses as well right the Lord has
signified that his work should be
carried forward in the same spirit in
which it was begun the world is to be
warned field after field is to be
entered the command given us is add new
territory shall we not as a people by
our business Arrangements by our
attitudes toward towards the world
unsaved bear a testimony even more clear
and decisive than that borne by US 20
and 30 years ago Martin the work is
great
yeah and
uh sometimes you feel this
compulsion that something needs to be
done the world needs to be reached and
that's why we at Clash of minds are not
thinking locally we are thinking
internationally and the work has to be
taken to every tribe and people and
nation and Kingdom and tongue how do you
do that everything has to be
translated everything has to be sent out
in different countries so that's why we
started the work in Europe for
example and it has to go from there to
every nation in Europe and Beyond Europe
then we have to have the work in
Australia we have the work in New
Zealand we have to think how to reach
China and Japan how to
reach the the Middle East how to reach
all of the religious systems in the
world it is mindboggling it is scary
mhm the work is great the work is great
but you see the work was great even from
David's time that's the way it is and
you have to enter new Fields you have to
go and do the things that you think are
impossible just start and God will open
the
way so the Lord restricted by our
attitude the Lord would do great things
for the workers but their hearts are not
humble should the Lord work in them they
would become lifted up filled with
self-esteem and would dearit their
Brethren so as soon as you get a work to
do the danger is that you become
highminded yes that's and and that's a
big problem so when you go into the
field or wherever you join a Ministry or
anything it's important to to remember
the the happy willingness to do it not
to
become
oh I'm dissatisfied I'm not getting out
of this what I wanted so how does the
Lord deal with this now
now Paul's name first was Saul then
became Paul but actually it's the same
name the one is just the Hebrew version
and the other one is the Latin version
yes yes but in the scripture he's called
Paul uhhuh now because he's called Paul
that means that the attributes applied
to that name are important and the
attribute applied to the name means
humble yeah now Paul was the Great
teacher apart from Christ That Ever
Walked on this Earth yeah that comes
from the spirit of
Prophecy that could have gone to his
head oh for sure so what did he get he
got a thorn in his side to keep him a
little bit
humble he got a couple of bonsers on the
bean in other words and the same happens
to those that think that they are the
bees knees right so the Lord Ways and
Means of
counteracting this attribute of humanity
that they think that they have become
something once they you know receive a
Proficiency in something we have to
remain humble we have to realize that
it's it's not us it is not any power
inherent in any individual that enables
you to do that for 40 years of my life I
never worked for God yeah so what
changed
no something had to change right
something I don't think only something
everything had to change correct so
who's responsible for that who must get
the glory for that only God can only God
what changed you only God and you
there's not time to say okay I'll work
on some things when God needs you to
change it right now okay continue the
story oh Lord God of Abraham Isaac and
of Israel Our Father keep this forever
in the imagination of the thoughts of
the heart of thy people and prepare
their heart unto thee and give unto
Solomon my son a perfect heart to keep
the Commandments thy testimonies and thy
statutes to do these things and to build
the palace for which I have made
provision so give unto Solomon my son a
perfect heart that entails keeping the
Commandments listening to the
testimonies and the statutes then you
can build yes then you can build and
that's the only time you can build this
Temple okay let's take this to the New
Testament to the spiritual house ye also
are Lively stones are built up a
spiritual house and a holy priesthood to
offer up spiritual
sacrifices acceptable to God by Jesus
Christ Martin the the typology is so
beautiful 1 Kings 517 and the King
commanded and they brought great Stones
costly Stones huge stones to lay the
foundation of the
house now we cannot build on any
foundation other than Christ that's it
so all these rocks and stones refer back
to him and those that are built on top
of him must be in his
similitude so they must have adopted
that character they must have accepted
the righteousness of Christ so the self
must die and he must be the one that is
in the
work all these were of costly Stones
according to the measure of hued stones
soord with swords within and without
even from the foundation unto the coping
and so on the outside towards the great
court so the whole
building from the foundation up had to
be swn and squared and hued
mhm and above were costly stones after
the measure of the huge stones and
Cedars and the great Court roundabout
was with three rows of huge stones and a
row of Cedar beams both for the inner
Court of the house of the Lord and for
the porch of the house can anyone be
excluded if these stones are living
stones
no but you're going to have
to work a little bit
against and go through some things it's
not always going to be easy no it's not
going to be easy and David said to the
congregation now bless the Lord your God
and all the congregation bless the Lord
God of their fathers bowed down their
heads and worshiped the Lord and the
king and they sacrificed sacrifices unto
the Lord and offered burnt offerings
unto the Lord on the tomorrow after that
day even a thousand Bullocks a thousand
Rams a thousand lambs and their drink
offerings and sacrifice and abundance
for all of Israel those were the
physical ones what would be the
spiritual ones everything that you have
has to be sacrificed to towards God
every talent that you have everything
must be in harmony with that Martin you
can't do it if you're not converted no
you can't so if you if you don't feel a
necessity to do any of these things then
you need to go down on your knees you
need to say God changed my heart there
can not be anything of Self in there
take it away take it away I don't want
it I don't want to be part of it and
then Solomon was anointed as king and
eat and drink before the Lord in that
day with great gladness and they made
Solomon the son of David the king the
second time and anointed him unto the
Lord to be the chief governor and zadok
to be a priest then Solomon sat on the
throne of the Lord as King instead of
David his father and prospered and all
Israel obeyed him here is a type of
Christ yes this is what has to happen
and you cannot worship without obeying
they go hand in hand we just saw that in
the previous one as well in Acts chapter
5 it says the holy spirit that is given
to them that oy him if people would look
at that attribute a lot of the
counterfeit Spirits would be exposed
that's it easily because you cannot have
the spirit if you do not keep the
Commandments that's
plain okay and all the princes and the
Mighty Men and all the sons like
acquires of King David submitted
themselves unto Solomon the king and the
Lord magnified Solomon exceedingly in
the sight of all Israel and bestowed
upon Him such Royal Majesty as had not
been on any King before him in Israel
this is typology of the highest order
irrespective of the apostasy of Solomon
later this is the type that has to
be uh reach
and then David died thus David the son
of Jesse reigned over all Israel and the
time that he reigned over Israel was 40
years 7 years reigny in Hebron 30 and3
years reigny in Jerusalem and he died in
a good old age full of days Martin this
verse makes me incredibly
uncomfortable because he wasn't um very
old he was 70 years old
in fact this verse freaks me
out riches and honor and Solomon his son
reigned in his stead now the acts of
David the king first and last behold
they are written in the book of Samuel
the Sea and the Book of Nathan the
prophet and the Book of GAD The Seer and
with all his Reign and his might and the
times that went over him and over Israel
over all the kingdom of the countries
you know what's interesting interesting
to me
Martin is that the book of Samuel this
year the book of Nathan and the Book of
GAD or not in the Bible correct but they
were prophets for that time and
therefore they were considered as books
essential to the children of Israel
correct so they were authorative uhhuh
could there be prophetic books that are
not part of the cannon that could be as
essential in the time that we live in
they are they are for
sure now Martin what is very important
if you have such books that there must
be in absolute harmony with everything
that the Bible says correct there can't
be some in harmony like we've mentioned
when we discussed the Book of Enoch you
cannot have some of it in line with the
Bible and then some of it totally
contradicting it correct
so here is a situation in the Old
Testament
where a physical Temple was built
prophets are mentioned that are not per
se as books in the
Bible and they are mentioned as
important to listen to and to take note
of right does God in his end time Church
also provide a testimony yes we read
before how important the law the
testimony
and the statutes are all
right so in the end time church when we
are talking about the spiritual house
that has been building for 2,000 years
now and I believe we are in the final
final
Gathering and the final Gathering comes
after Babylon has
fallen and
multitudes are
entrapped in the Babylonian systems so
here is a great work that must be
carried forward to call a people out of
Babylon isn't that what our task is
that's our task isn't it important that
we tell people who Babylon is that's it
isn't it important to tell about the
Corruptions that have come into Babylon
and why people should leave them yes
isn't it important to tell them what
they should leave to for sure isn't it
important that the law and the testimony
become prominent that's part of the
Revelation to be qualified to be the
remnant Church isn't it important that
the Everlasting gospel be preached again
because it has been snippet up into non
Everlasting portions that you get in the
first Angel's message isn't it important
that we warn against the mark of the be
yeah we've done it in um the SEC third
Angel's message is it important that we
speak about the righteousness of Christ
not for the whole not only for the whole
body but for the individual as well for
sure isn't it important that we say how
important it is that the righteousness
of Christ be
manifested by your work so that people
can see that you have the true
righteousness and not the spous one
yeah does the world know about these
things no is it a great work that needs
to be done it's the Great and final work
isn't it time now to put the shoulder to
the wheel there's no better time than
now so this is our appeal Brothers and
Sisters in Christ and all who are
acquainted with the work for this time
time to put the shoulder to the wheel
the work is great and the workers of few
may the Lord impress you as to what role
you and I and everybody involved should
play in this great work for this time
let's pray amen Heavenly
Father it is scary to see how great the
work is and how confused the world
is and we know that there will be great
opposition because Babylon will never
acknowledge that it has
fallen it is of its nature to say that
it is unfallen and the way to
salvation but we know that it is the way
of
petion and people need to be
warned Lord help us all to put the
shoulder to the wheel and to bring about
that great loud cry so that people can
be
Warn and the firmament can roll back
like a scroll and Christ descend and
come to fetch his people this is my
prayer in jesus' name amen
[Music]
amen